what do you think about influencers and
celebrities that supported FTX and SBF
do they should they be punished yeah I
think I think I should take a huge
reputational hit I mean I think they
should be embarrassed I think they
should be ashamed of themselves but it
was really hard to know sorry to
interrupt for them to know like for
example I think about this a lot yeah
it's like
who do I
because I don't investigate you know
like uh sponsored by athletic greens
okay it's a nutritional drink should I
investigate them deeply I don't I don't
know you just kind of use reputational
like it seems to work for me should I
like I think I think it really depends
on I think your credibility hit will
depend on what domain you're an expert
in if you're sponsored by a robotics
company
and you're an expert in robotics if that
company turns out to be a disaster and
fraud then you should have looked more
deeply we're talking mostly about like I
hold Tom Brady a lot less accountable
than financial advisors Financial
influencers because that is their world
of expertise and you treat their Rec
recommendation differently
proportionally to what you think their
expertise is so in some ways I don't
actually think Tom Brady I'm sure you
reached a lot of people I personally
didn't feel it all moved by his
recommendation because you know it's
just money
but when you hear somebody who should be
an expert in that thing
endorse a product in that space you hold
that opinion to a higher standard and
when they're completely
cataclysmically wrong it's going to be a
different level of accountability and I
think rightfully so when um Jim Cramer
in was saying bear Stearns is fine he
made that terrible call and bear with
bear Stearns in 2008. he was rightfully
reamed for all of that even though it
could be considered that like well you
know did he have all the information
maybe not but he's a financial advisor
he does this for a living if you go on
and you make a big call and you turn out
to be wrong and people lose tons of
money
you are going to take a hit I think
rightfully so but no I don't think these
people should go to jail or anything
like that like oh it's such a
complicated thing I mean I just feel it
personally myself I get it but you still
feel the burden of the fact that you're
opinion has influence I know it
shouldn't I know Tom Brady's opinion on
financial investments should not
influence but it does right that's just
the reality of it right that's a real
burden I didn't know anything about SPF
or FTX it wasn't on my radar at all
um but I could see myself like taking
them on as a sponsor I've seen a lot of
people I respect uh Sam Harris and
others like talk talk with SPF uh like
he's doing good for the world so I could
see myself being Hoodwinked having not
done research and the same thing makes
me wonder
like I I don't want to become cynical
and uh but it makes you wonder who are
the people in your life you trust that
are like that could be the next SPF or
or Worse big powerful leaders Hitler and
all that kind of stuff
um
to what degree do you want to
investigate do you want to uh hold their
feet to the fire see through their
[ __ ] call them on their [ __ ] and
also as a friend if you happen to be
friends or have a connection how to help
them not slip into the land of fraud I
don't know all of this is just
overwhelming yeah I mean I mean we
should be clear like Finance is sort of
a special space
where
you're talking about people's money
you're not talking about whether people
someone takes a bad supplement or like a
supplement that is just they're fifty
dollars out right
I think the scale of harm yeah and
therefore responsibility escalates
depending on what field you're in just
like I wouldn't hold Tom Brady as like
if he gives a bad football opinion right
and he should have known better that is
a different scale of harm than a doctor
giving bad advice right like life's it
like he tells you a pill works and the
pill kills you or something like that
there's just different levels of
accountability depending on the field
you're in and you have to be aware of it
Finance is an extra you have to be
extremely conservative if you're going
to give Financial advice because you're
playing with people's lives and you
cannot play with them haphazardly you
cannot gamble with them you cannot play
with them on a bet because you're
getting paid a lot of money
it's just the nature of the space and so
with the with the space comes the
responsibility and the accountability
and I I don't think you can get around
that